Doris yes let vine armies worry about
guitars for tonight while the mighty
Zeus enjoys some diversions of a more
sapphic nature yeah now we've got a
bunch of ladies yeah order to play that
we I was going to turn to my wife
Jennifer and she said I'm not playing
hookers so I turned to my second wife
Jason News saying the role of the ladies
of the evening that Maxie Zeus will
sleep with an actor who's been in a few
movies himself but has never had the
challenge of playing a woman let alone
four mmm Jason Mewes yeah come join us
oh I'm gonna jump in I'm used to doing
this don't worry about that suck do it
better and action come join us
oh my shoes would you [ __ ] it
alright that one passes let's see you
the next one we live only to serve a god
why don't close who's that man Michael
Clarke Duncan got in the room that's a
transgender right there Oh
it's okay oh that's his choice Jason
Mewes made a choice mouth with grapes I
don't care how beautiful the woman looks
if she sounds like that I'm running
alright that's that's good does she is
gonna let this video design mouth with
grapes and do you know any other foreign
accents oi and other stuff too this is
the Joker and a woman's costume he's
hiding from you he's gonna substitute
his penis off alright man standing
nearby
that was I was not very yeoman like
performance wah Costas is that Bob
Costas Costas take that leave of me that
I might indulge these virgins with the
power of Zeus as you wish my lord
hey dude nobody said to ad-lib
[Music]
you
[Music]